last night Republicans won a hotly
contested special election in Ohio
putting a full five out of five
candidates whom Trump endorsed over the
finish line
meanwhile Democrat superstar Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez strikes out losing four
out of five four out of six rather
endorsed races but don't worry don't
worry it's okay
Democrats and the mainstream media will
explain to us how losing is really
winning then professor Edward phasor
joins to rebuff Pope Francis's recent
creativity with Catholic doctrine in the
death penalty the Oscars finally
recognizes movies that people see and
CNN humiliates itself what else is new
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
so much to get to today and we have to
figure out we need CNN to tell us how
losing is winning and war is peace and
up is to happen before we get to that I
have to think blue apron got to thank
this wonderful sponsor blue apron let me
give you free food people listen to me
basically all I ate the all I ever eat
these days is blue apron sweet little
Lisa cooks it all the time it's shipped
right to my door it excellent recipes
they don't repeat recipes you get new
recipes all the time quick and easy
options perfectly portioned ingredients
delivered right to your door
blue apron makes dinner quick easy and
very very tasty so the quality of
ingredients you're not going to beat
anywhere the super chic organic grocery
store the quality of these meats and
ingredients you are not going to be
they're so good at blue apron seasonally
inspired ingredients mouth-watering
grilling options for summer chicken with
barbecue sauce
juicy cheeseburgers with coleslaw
they're all just they're so good chef
designed recipes exciting partnerships
like Bob's Burgers and master chef check
out this week's menu and listen listen
let me help you help me help you take
free food get your first three meals
free at blue apron calm slash cough FA
Co V Fe Fe blue apron dot-com cough FA
Co V Fe Fe get your first three meals
free it's free food you'd be a fool not
to do it go there right now blue apron a
better way to cook okay so I I'll be
honest with you I'll make a little
confession here I was that late on a
school night last night I was I went to
a local cigar bar I was at a friend's
birthday party had a couple Coca Cola's
a few adult beverages you know anyway I
roll in to my apartment a little late
last night late enough to see the
results of that hotly contested primary
election in or the hotly contested
special election in Ohio now what
happens this is the headline that I see
the main headline on Apple News you know
takes up the whole screen and then a
couple below it quote too close to call
too close for comfort
Trump's candidate appeared to eke out a
razor-thin win in Ohio but signs of a
why
a democratic waiver coming into focus
read more at USA Today then the next one
right below that Republicans now realize
how hard they'll have to fight in dozens
of similar races to regain control of
the house read more at BuzzFeed that's
my whole screen time looking at Apple
news now some things have - jeez that
sounds like terrible news for oh no it
means that the Republican one that's
what that means
I know that would be confusing because
every single word they used was designed
to make it seem like the Democrat won
but the Democrat lost the Republican one
no automatic recount no nothing nope a
Republican one this is what they do all
the time
Republican Troy Bulger sent beat
Democrat Danny O'Connor they the
Democrats always run certain that
they're gonna win so you've probably
read about this house race they've been
pumping it up in the last few days this
is the one the sign of the blue wave
Democrats are coming baby and then they
lose and then they pretend that losing
is winning they did this do you remember
John Assaf that candidate and probably
not but they you know there was this
candidate in Georgia and the Democrats
said like John Asif he is the one this
is the referendum on Trump Blue Wave
baby woo and then the election happens
and he loses they're like yeah well yeah
he lost but really secretly secretly
though he won well but it but the
numbers he law but no I know the numbers
and the other guy the other guys going
to Congress yeah no yeah I but secretly
though its moral victory there's no
there's no moral victory I don't go when
you win you go make legislation and when
you lose you go home
that's what happened that's what
happened at Ohio the Republican one haha
so Valders it right now he's ahead 1754
votes there are still provisional
ballots there are still absentee ballots
so sure anything could happen right but
there was no automatic recount triggered
he won he won the night so what they're
doing now that they can't they can't
figure out how to really spin it that
the Democrat won so they're blaming the
Green Party candidate for losing there's
this Green Party candidate in this race
Joe manchak and they're saying he got
almost enough votes to spur a recount an
automatic recount the operative word
here is almost he didn't he
didn't get a no votes to spur an
automatic recount sorry
but this is what they're saying that I'm
gonna introduce this guy to you first
and then I'll explain
Democrats bad strategy here Joe manchak
Green Party candidate in Ohio is from
hell Michigan fitting he says that his
ancestors were aliens quote my distant
relatives originally came to Planet
Earth from a planet orbiting a star in
the Pleiades star cluster located in the
constellation of Taurus which which
might make him an illegal alien I don't
know he but he probably has birthright
citizenship but his ancestors may have
been illegal aliens from outer space he
says that he speaks in 19 languages
including Spanglish and sheet music
those are and a few others I don't even
know that those are the two craziest
without further ado Green Party
candidate no hi Oh Joe Magic okay Joe
we're live um could you go ahead and
introduce yourself sure my name is Joe
man chick and I'm a Green Party
candidate running for the US House of
Representatives in a house 12th
congressional district this is the
second time I'm running for a seat in
the US House in the 12th district in
Ohio is on the ballot in 2016 and I got
more than 13,000 votes and I'm doing it
again this year
to donate to your campaign or volunteer
do you have a website yeah yeah I
definitely have a website and there's a
donate page there's a link for the
donate page at the top of the website
you can just click on that link and
it'll take you over to where you can use
a credit card or PayPal account to or
another kind of card we call what do you
call those cards yeah that's what I was
looking for a debit card I don't have
one of those so I can't remember what it
was but uh - wait what is that
just mail a check to the campaign
there's an address there where you can
just stop checking the mail we don't
take corporate money and if you send us
any corporate money it will send it
right back we know watch your corporate
money we don't want we don't take money
from corporations nobody in the Green
Party will take corporate money and
we'll return it if we get corporate
money so you know if you want to send
dissent hey if you want to support my
campaign please
send me a check from a personal account
now gladly accept that awesome and then
can you tell us what that website is
yeah I've chopped my hair I don't
remember for Congress dot wordpress.com
forward slash something forward slash
something that could be the new democrat
party motto forward slash something
that's that's what they're doing that's
their their mantra these days so the
best part of this Joe man chick is the
Democrats are complaining now because
they're calling him a spoiler all of the
mainstream media are calling him a
spoiler you know and that's the press
wing of the Democrat Party the
Democratic operatives themselves are
calling Joe mantric a spoiler they're
saying that all the votes that this guy
got would have gone to the Democrat so
just consider that for a second but
you're admitting that's more of a
confession really than an accusation
what you're saying is that the guys who
vote for the outer space alien who
doesn't have a debit card can't remember
his campaign website that guy wearing
you probably couldn't see it but I sort
of ratty t-shirt with a peace sign on it
that guy would there in your there in
your constituency there in your base
they would have gone for your candidate
I would probably that's not a great
long-term strategy so he's a spoiler I
would say no he was a no they would have
all voted for the Republican no oh wait
sir II would they vote for us uh uh uh
really really said the other the other
headlined the true headline that you
could see in a few outlets today it's
quote Democrat parties liberal
insurgency hits a wall and I don't want
to say that I told you so well I do I do
want to say that I want to take write
afford I did tell you this would happen
I used that exact metaphor I don't
remember who was on this show or I
another show that I was appearing on but
I did point out that the the Democrats
if they double down on this far left
Alexandria Cassio Cortes strategy they
are running right into a wall in the
midterms this is not going to work
Democrats could win in the midterms but
these socialista candidates ain't going
to happen
and the mainstream media seem to be
picking up on that maybe they watch this
show here's what happened
the really far left candidates for
Michigan governor that was a race up
last night former state senator Gretchen
Whitmer beat Abdul Elsayed
a Muslim socialist who is his doctor
he's endorsed by Bernie Sanders he's
endorsed by these socialists he lost
that race the socialist Bernie backed
guy by 20 points he lost that primary by
20 points
he ended fourth in a 5-way race not
great st. Louis congressional
congressman William lacy clay beat out a
socialist black lives matter activist
Corey Bush Corey Bush was endorsed by
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes beat beat Corey
Bush handily ocasion court has struck
out broadly over the night okay as your
Cortes an endorsed six candidates going
into these races she was flying all over
to Michigan she's been flying all over
the country for candidates she's been in
California raising money and she struck
out four out of those six candidates
lost and turned out pretty Webb pretty
badly Elsayed coming out fourth out of
fifth fourth out of five that's not
really good
Brent welder lost he issued or sprint
welder James Thompson won that's one of
the candidates who won Rashidah clabe
won Rasheeda clay but could be the first
Muslim congresswoman she is known
exclusively for heckling Trump at an
event once that is her only
qualification to enter the US Senate but
she won she was one of the more radical
candidates who who won last night she's
never held a job in her entire life she
is a career politician for if you look
at her wiki page it says early life and
education politics there's no there's no
nothing in between it's early life
straight into hackery politics then
there was another headline another sort
of exciting unseen before candidate
unconventional the headline was quote
possible first gay Native American woman
in Congress wins which is really a
shocking headline because I had no idea
that Elizabeth Warren was gay it never
occurred to me that she I don't know if
she was married to a guy at one time so
that's incredible congratulations to you
senator Lyle waffle Warren for coming
out no I guess suppose there was another
Native American
who's actually Native American named
Cherise David's she was a White House
Fellow under the Obama administration
she was endorsed she was not endorsed by
Alexandria okay Jie Cortez
okay Zhu Cortes endorsed from print
welder in that race and she won so
that'll be another area where identity
politics are there pouring that down
your throats they're gonna try to do
something about that so okay they've
never asked they just lost and and in
particular the left wing of the Democrat
Party lost last night so how are they
spinning it they're spinning it and
saying that okay sure they lost the
races but their turnout was excellent
their turnout was way way better
especially in Michigan so in Michigan
the GOP turnout was a turnout overall by
the way was up
but GOP turnout was up 24% and Democrat
turnout was up 84% something like that
some really high number GOP the reason
for this is that the GOP infighting is
not like the Democrat infighting right
now just consider the stakes right now
everything is going great for the
country and the Republican Party is
leading the country so everything's
going great for the Republican Party
just going really really well the
economy Foreign Affairs domestic policy
it's all going great other than our
crazy spending but other than that it's
going very very well so what are the
Republicans fighting for so relatively
low stakes we just have to fight to hold
it in the general election the Democrats
are fighting for the soul of their party
they're still furious because Hillary
stole that nomination from Bernie
Sanders the Democrats stole that they
played unfit unfairly at least I don't
know if they play fairly would Bernie
have won I don't know maybe not but they
certainly played very unfairly with him
and so they're fighting over this the
progressive wing of the party versus the
more centrist types and so that's why
the the numbers are up they are actually
doing battle in their primaries the
Republicans really aren't doing battle
in their primaries so it doesn't they're
using this random statistic to try to
prove their point even when all the
other facts disprove their point and
they're doing this again it's pretty sad
we should get to the crazy ocasion
cortes if at all although I might bring
to have Professor phaser on so you ready
to go okay now all right then we'll
start talking about Ocasio Cortes first
the Ocasio Cortes of it all is is why
the
lefty Democrats are running up against
the wall she's the reason I Alexandria
Casio Cortez the future of the Democrat
Party according to Tom Perez doesn't
know anything she's crazy she's crazy
eyed and she doesn't know anything you
know you got to remember when you're
talking about the these races four out
of six losing last night a Tom Perez the
head of the DNC said she is the future
of the party well if she's the future of
the party the future of the party looks
bleak it does not look very good for you
does it because what's the future of the
Republican Party right now the the now
is the future it's going very very well
but I don't know perhaps the Democrats
should consider a new future because
okay as your Cortez does not seem to be
a winner I'm gonna get to her interview
with pod save America in a second but
first I want to bring on Professor
Edward phasor professor phasor you on I
am on good thank you so much for being
here
professor phasor is the author of by man
shall his blood be shed a Catholic
defense of capital punishment he's the
associate professor of philosophy at
Pasadena City College
he's called by National Review one of
the best contemporary writers on
philosophy I'm sure you've read his
columns before he's written about a
zillion books
professor phasor we have talked a little
bit this week on this show about Pope
Francis's recent statements on the death
penalty
I share your views on the death penalty
I rather like it I think hanging
concentrates the mind I think it's
rather justified how first of all before
we even talk about this
what does Pope Francis's statement on
the death penalty look like compared to
2,000 years of Catholic tradition well
at the very least it has to be said that
this that the revision of the Catechism
that the Pope introduced last week is
ambiguous on the one hand there is the
there is the affirmation in the cover
letter that was that accompanied the
revision of the Catechism issued by the
Congregation for the Doctrine of the
Faith which claimed that there's no
contradiction with past teaching okay
that sounds good but on the other hand
when you look at the actual text of the
Catechism and the Pope uses language to
the effect
that the death penalty is what he calls
an attack on the inviolability and
dignity of the person that certainly
sounds like it's claiming that capital
punishment is intrinsically evil that
it's wrong of its very nature and that
would manifestly be in conflict with the
traditional teaching of the church since
you see precisely the office of that
opposite of that thesis affirm
consistently throughout Scripture
affirmed by Pope after Pope for two
thousand years affirmed in previous
church documents of a high level of
authority such as the Roman catechism
issued by pope saint pius v and the two
previous versions of the catechism
issued by john paul ii who despite his
own personal opposition to capital
punishment and his personal hope that it
be abolished consistently affirmed that
it can be illegitimate in principle and
and applied in practice at least in very
rare cases that was Pope John Paul the
second here so Pope Francis's view seems
to radically go beyond anything any
previous Pope has said including
Pope John Paul the second seems to I
emphasize now it would be nice to have
some clarification of how what's being
said now can be made consistent the
claim there's a claim that there's no
contradiction but as I've noted
elsewhere just to say there's no
contradiction doesn't explain how P and
not P but what seems to be P and not B
can be made consistent of course and you
see this not just in the statements of
Pope's and in other high-level church
documents you see it from the writings
of st. Paul st. Agustin st. Thomas
Aquinas all affirming the legitimacy of
the death penalty and now we have
something different and correct me if
I'm wrong
didn't pope francis elsewhere in a more
casual setting say that the death
penalty is contrary to the gospel he did
in fact the the statement you're
thinking of was in a speech from last
october where he first raised the
possibility of revising the catechism
and the language he used then was that
capital punishment was quote per se
contrary to the gospel unquote which
certainly does seem to say that capital
punishment is intrinsically wrong that's
intrinsically contrary to Christian
morality now fortunately the Pope didn't
use that sort of language in the
Catechism
what you see in the revision as I've
said it does seem to be very problematic
but it's not quite as blatant or extreme
as that remark that he made in October
and and it's you know if I could comment
on that remark from October some people
have suggested well maybe if you said
that capital punishment is per se a
contrary of the gospel maybe you could
make that consistent with the idea that
it's not contrary to natural law the
idea of you okay so we could say that
it's that natural law allows it but the
higher demands of the gospel rule it out
oh I'm sorry that won't work either
because Pope after Pope from innocent
Pope Innocent the first two Pope
Innocent the third two pius v two Pius
the tenth two john paul ii and percent
all they were all addressing
specifically Christian audiences and in
context like catechisms that were
supposed to guide Christians they're
supposed to guide Catholics explicitly
said that capital punishment can
sometimes be used so even if he were to
say that capital punishment which is
contrary to Christian morality
specifically to the higher demands of
the gospel that would also be a
contradiction with tradition not merely
a development of course and and even the
language used here in this revision to
the Catechism an attack on the
inviolability of the dignity of the
person it is very hard to read that and
not conclude that the present Pope
believes that the church has been
teaching an error if for two millennia
yeah
my practical question then is for
Catholics who have a legitimate
disagreement about capital punishment or
who support capital punishment or who
read these statements from the Pope and
say this doesn't seem to jive very well
how should Catholics react I'm always so
loathe to openly criticize the Pope but
certain things seem to breed a total
confusion or to be an error yeah well
some Catholics who are well-meaning have
a deep misunderstanding of what the
church says about the authority of a
pope it's fairly well known that that
not everything a pope says is infallible
so a lot of people realize that but they
still think that even when the Pope
doesn't teach something infallibly that
you must under absolutely every
circumstance go along with that
that's not actually correct in the end
the church very recently you know about
20 years ago under pope john paul ii
made it clear in the document known as
done in veritatis which discusses the
duties of theologians it allowed them
that a church document could it could be
deficient in different ways and that
catholic theologians had the right and
sometimes even the duty to respectfully
raise criticisms to point out problems
now there couldn't be any clearer
problem with a document there couldn't
be any clearer case of a deficiency then
a magisterial document a church
documents seeming to contradict 2,000
years of past teaching because after all
the church has repeatedly said that
popes have no authority to introduce new
doctrines when the first Vatican Council
declared the infallibility of the Pope
it explicitly said this that the Pope
has no authority to make up something
new but only to preserve and safeguard
what has been passed on and you can
refine what's been passed on you can
draw out implications from it but you
can't reverse it
you can't contradict it and a pope
benedict xvi famously reaffirm this and
and argued for what he called a
hermeneutic of continuity always
interpreting present teaching in light
of the past in consistency with the past
so the church allows when when a pope or
anyone else says something that is that
appears to be in actual contradiction
with tradition church allows theologians
to raise respectful criticisms and to
ask the church to to reaffirm continuity
with tradition you know I'm reminded I
think Chesterton said that a heresy is
not the promotion of Vice / virtue it's
the promotion of one virtue to the
exclusion of the others you know mercy
to the exclusion of prudence or justice
for instance in this case perhaps very
broadly for people who are unaware or
who are divided over the death penalty I
know Catholics who were quite personally
opposed to the death penalty even if
they don't think it's anti gospel
conservatives who are opposed to the
death penalty because they believe that
the state shouldn't have the power to
kill people what what do you see if you
can give a 30
thousand foot view as the support for
the death penalty and the support for
what the Pope seems to be saying now
from scripture or tradition yeah well
what'd you find in Scripture tradition
and my co-author Joseph the set and I in
our book by man shall his blood be shed
it's the Catholic defense of capital
punishment what we demonstrate is that
you find in the tradition of the church
a middle ground position between two
extremes on the one extreme is the claim
that capital punishment is of its very
nature intrinsically evil the church has
definitively ruled that out consistently
on the other extreme would be the view
that you must always absolutely always
inflict on someone the penalty that he
or she deserves including death well the
church has always reject that as well
there may be cases where someone
deserves a punishment even capital
punishment but there might nevertheless
be reasons why you should refrain from
giving the person what what he deserves
some it might even be moral reasons why
you might do that so the church has
never insisted that you must always
inflict capital punishment on someone
who deserves it
but between those two extreme positions
the church has always allowed Catholics
freely discuss this issue and at some
points in church history the tendency
has been to advocate you know for rarely
if ever using capital punishment that
was true in the earliest centuries of
the church and in recent decades for
most of the history of the church the
tenant seems to think that capital
punishment could be used in a fairly
wide variety of cases now I think that
what's happened I think this is
especially true of Pope Saint John Paul
the second is that some 20th century
governments have been so brutal Nazi
Germany and the Soviet Union come to
mind or communist China under Mao Zedong
for example we're so brutal that I and
the pope john paul ii of course had
direct experience of those regimes that
i think there was a tendency to want to
pull away from an emphasis on
retributive justice and focus instead on
rehabilitation and so forth right and
you can certainly make you could
certainly make that case but one of the
things we argue in our book is that it's
it's possible to go too far in that
direction and if you go too far and you
start condemning capital punishment and
he's extreme
describing it as a violation of human
dignity and so forth then you start to
lose the other side of the tradition and
indeed you start to lose sight of the
very idea that there's such a thing as
getting one is just dessert so that
there is a cosmic moral order that's
upset when we don't and let the
punishment fit the crime we don't let it
ever fit the crime and so forth we lose
sight of that and of course there's also
this danger in the Catholic context of
seeming to sever the tradition entirely
from its origin seventy several current
teaching from its from its origins of
course if the category if I could I'm
sorry go ahead
yeah well I was just gonna add what
often gets lost in this discussion also
is that Catholics have discussed this
issue and who oppose capital punishment
routinely speak as if it were
uncontroversial that we could take it
for granted that capital punishment has
no deterrent effect or that it's not
important for protecting individuals
from aggressors and we argue in the book
that's simply not the case for one thing
if you're going to say that modern
prison systems are sufficient to keep
people safe from from the the most
dangerous criminals and so forth well at
best you can say that's true in
developed countries in in Europe and the
United States and Canada in places like
that there are lot of undeveloped areas
of the world third world countries where
that's not the case where you don't have
sufficient you don't have adequate
prison systems to keep people to keep
people safe you've got for example the
famous escapes of El Chapo and Mexican
the Mexican drug lord
obviously the prison system there was
not sufficient to keep people safe from
this from this murderous person right
that's just that's just one example but
of course even in even in developed
countries a murderer who's in prison for
life can still pose a danger to prison
guards prison guards sometimes get
murdered by these people other prisoners
sometimes an organized crime figure
might call in an assassination from
within prison to outside prison walls we
argue that there's considerable evidence
that that capital punishment has
deterrence value so if you get rid of it
you're risking innocent lives and it
also provides an important tool for
prosecutors in plea bargaining you might
get someone who's on trial who doesn't
want to give information about his
accomplices or information about other
crimes and if you tell him look we could
seek the death penalty for you but we
won't if you play ball and give us
information about these other things
sometimes they're willing to do that
whereas if you take the death penalty
off the books you no longer have that
option and once again innocent lives
will be in danger so we really care
about protecting the innocent
we can't just dismiss capital punishment
cavalierly on the basis of vague slogans
about human dignity and so forth that
that would also contradict the tradition
that church in any case we are awash
these days in politics in vague slogans
from at least one side of politics and
it's really upsetting because it seems
to me that the people who were rallying
most and most vociferously to get rid of
capital punishment couldn't possibly
tell you why we have capital punishment
to begin with they couldn't explain it
they couldn't defend it which is usually
a good sign that they don't know what
they're talking about an excellent book
though by man shall his blood be shed a
Catholic defense of capital punishment
professor Fraser I have to let you go
but we'll have to have you come back
because it is a great relief as a
conservative and certainly as a Catholic
to have a little clarity in these days
when there is so much confusion going
around thank you very much for having me
on thanks for coming okay all right
we've got to get back we've got to get
back to Alexandria Cassio Cortes do I
have time to go through Cortes before I
sign off Facebook am I allowed to will
you give me okay I'm I'm doing it tough
too bad I'm doing it here we go uh don't
say I never did nothing for you people
so Alexandria Cassio Cortes this is just
too good to miss she just did an
interview on pod save America you know
that's the one where all those soy
swallowing you know these just they're
all there they're just devouring soy
products during their podcast they're
the X Obama Bros who do this show where
their take on politics is to say the F
word in a really whiny voice and that's
somehow political analysis and insight
anyway Alexandria o Cassio Cortes goes
on pod save America and you don't need
Allie Stuckey for this she made an even
bigger fool of herself here is
Alexandria o Cassio Cortes
rajat enormous sanga's página commercial
night you and political prodigy Lutz
hmph engine but a Muslim dish sweetener
yella errand boy when a police to
discover kappa tammeh if it stylized
Furby gimmick not see in : a new
political I'm sorry that was my mistake
I put ok as hero cortezes interview on
in the original Russian but I should do
the English translation we will bury you
we will bury you do we have the English
version of okay SEO Cortez we don't talk
about what defense costs we're about to
eat a trillion dollars in debt because
of the corporate tax cuts yet when we
talk about pre-k health care college
suddenly it's unrealistic because of
cost and it's not just bad faith
Republicans that make that argument you
hear it from Democrats as well what's
your response to that well I think it's
that same exact thing it's that we you
know they say how are you gonna pay for
it as though they haven't used these
same ways to pay for unlimited wars to
pay for trillion dollar tax cuts and tax
cut extensions they use these mechanisms
to pay for these things all the time
they only want to know it just seems
like their pockets are only empty when
we're talking about education and
investing in human capital in the United
States education health care housing and
investing in the middle class yeah I
just want to pause it there did you
catch that phrase she used human capital
I don't know about you I get a chill up
my spine I get a little nervous start
sweating a little bit when a socialist
starts talking about human capital like
I'm just a commodity like I'm a pure
product and no Michael it's alright
we're gonna use your human capital in a
different way da da people use your
Jumman capital da No thank you ma'am no
please don't use me they do this all the
time the left talks about people like
their animals or commodities or just
masses of flesh to be used however they
see fit because that is true they say
okay doctors you're gonna do what we
tell you to do okay you workers you're
gonna do what we tell you to do and hey
give us all your money we'll give you
back
a little bit don't worry we know we know
what's best human capital just a little
use event it's another turn of phrase
that the left uses all the time which is
really terrifying and wicked she goes on
me I think it belies a lack of moral
priority and it's unfortunate I think
that but I also think a lot of these
folks especially those I think perhaps
from the Democratic side perhaps they
don't even see it you know I don't know
I don't know if that's a generous
interpretation or not but I think that
they start kind of buying into
conservative talking points they get
dragged into their court all the time
and I think it is because there's this
really myopic and also just
misunderstanding of politics as this
flat two-dimensional left right thing
and so they always feel like okay the
right says this thing we have to respond
to it and that's why they're winning
what what well what was that what was
any of that did you the question was how
are you gonna pay for it how are you
gonna pay for it that would you so the
quick let's just go through Hearst her
stream-of-consciousness that is how are
you gonna pay for it yeah I had french
toast for breakfast this morning with
maple syrup and maple syrup comes from
Vermont which is in the Northeast of
America and when you cross the Atlantic
Ocean you get to Britain and Britain has
two syllables and two is the number
after one are you ever gonna wake not
what is that
so the question she's asked how are you
gonna pay for your crazy socialist
programs here is her stream of thought
in in real time I'll try to clean it up
a little bit from the UM zand the AWS
and the hi don't knows
she says saying the same mechanisms as
we used to pay for unlimited wars and
tax cuts so I think when she started but
unlimited Wars I think she's talking
about the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan
which have gone on for seventeen years
according to the CBO the total costs of
those wars over seventeen years two
point four trillion dollars two point
four trillion dollars that makes it 141
billion dollars per year what is the
cost of her Medicare for all plan or so
health care plan three point two
trillion dollars per year three point
two trillion dollars per year versus 141
billion dollars per year so her program
just that one program by the way not all
of her programs just that one will cost
twenty two point seven times more than
the Iraq and Afghanistan wars in fact
it'll cost significantly more per year
than the entire cost of both the wars in
Iraq and Afghanistan so I don't think
that's gonna work what's the question of
tax cuts there's no cost of tax cuts
there's no cost of tax cuts it's just
letting people keep more of their money
that's not a cost that's not a payout
that's not giving somebody money it's
not taking as much of the money as you
previously had taken that's what a tax
cut is so okay twenty two point seven
times more expensive than Iraq and
Afghanistan wars but you know look she's
not the expert alexandria cassia Krista
she's not the expert on math or anything
else next she mumbles incoherently about
scarcity she just says work she uses the
word scarcity in she juxtaposes it next
to other words she doesn't say anything
she then says America has a lack of
moral priority which is unfortunate she
then uses the word folks so you know
that she's a Democrat shits folks
Democrat folks they don't see it she
says I don't know then she says
Democrats by conservative talking points
Democrats are myopic I can agree with
that one I agree with one thing she said
she says there's a flat understanding of
politics flat you know like a left-right
thing man it's just really you know man
it's flat and that's why Republicans win
and Democrats don't have a strong
message truer words have never been said
that's Democrats don't have a strong
message I count like ten bullet points
they're not once did she even attempt to
answer the question she she she said a
slogan about war and tax cuts at no
point did she attempt to answer the
question how are you gonna pay
why cause you obviously she doesn't know
she can't there's no way to pay for all
this crazy stuff unless you become just
a full-on socialist country which is
probably what she wants and even then
the money is certainly going to dry up
because in socialism eventually you run
out of other people's money we have a
lot more to get to I want to talk a
little bit more about
and the Oscars change and a final word
on Alex Jones before I do that you've
got to go to daily wire comm if you're
on Facebook and YouTube thank you very
much and I'm and I really thank you to
Facebook and YouTube for not censoring
us yet I'm sure that one's coming but if
you're a daily wire thank you help us
keep the lights on go over there now why
you get all the shows you can ask
questions in the mailbag get those in
that's gonna be tomorrow you get to ask
questions in conversation blah blah blah
oh is that oh you know what this is this
is the Ohio special election for Co mm
hmm hmm what's that tape
it tastes like Democrats saying that
they secretly won but they didn't they
lost that's what it tastes like that's a
really good mm-hmm it tastes like five
out of five Trump endorse candidates
winning in four out of six
Alexandria Casio endorsed candidates
losing that's what it tastes like it
tastes really good and you're gonna need
it because there are more elections
around the corner go to daily wire.com
I'll be right back
okay and our final or final moments
together here today I do want to talk
about the change to the Oscars so the
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences has finally realized that
people don't like them very much and
don't watch the award shows and really
don't watch the movies so they've
announced some major changes to the
award show last year the the Oscars
telecast was down 19 percent in views
huge almost 20 percent down in
viewership and that was down over the
previous year which was a nine year low
nobody is watching this telecast anymore
so they have to do something they've
announced a few plans they're going to
shorten the telecast they're going to
take some of the awards for like
assistant deputy sound editing pogo
stick jumper and they're going to put
that during the commercial breaks and
then truncate it for the end because no
one watches those awards that will see
that guilds are gonna be very upset
about that but we'll see what happens
there the big change is that there's a
new category the new category is for
outstanding achievement in popular film
now you might be asking well isn't
there's an award for Best Motion Picture
right yes there is but now we know per
the Andrew Clavin theory of art forms
that movies are done movies are done
that the dru can talk about it more on
his show but his basic theory is that
when our art diverges and you've got two
categories when you've got the
categories that the critics and the
artists like and the category that the
people like then it's dead
it's just totally separated and it's
dead and that's what you're seeing here
I mean it's such a it's so spitting in
the face of these popular filmmakers and
of their audience they're saying oh well
not everybody won't watch moonlight
because they're so stupid they won't
even watch moonlight so okay we'll give
one to Star Wars or something and
they're just they're separating this
category it means it's dead because
there is now a categorical distinction
between movies that people watch and
movies that are considered artistic
they're considered great movies that
absolutely and nobody watches here is an
example of this because you know what
the popular movies are
it's the Marvel movies it's Star Wars
it's whatever not the last Star Wars but
the other Star Wars those are popular
and then the other movies they're like
moonlight you know the ones about like
it's always about like lesbian Cowboys
or something and nobody's gonna go watch
it 30 rock saw this coming years and
years ago
here is a tracy Jordan making his Oscar
bait movie the movie that wins Best
Picture hard to watch cuz he's my
brother
don't say nothing sometimes you gotta do
the right thing your mother exploded
that's it that is every Best Picture
winner probably since the Lord of the
Rings Return of the King which was 15
years ago at this point right that was I
think it was 2003 that ever they're just
called hard to watch I'm gonna win my
Oscar nobody's gonna watch this movie
but it's hard to watch that's it that's
what they're gonna do so now they have
the popular movie category it's it's
really sad I guess it's good that
popular movies now will be shown at the
Oscars but it's too little too late
you're you're admitting that the people
who watch the Oscars and the people who
go to movies those few people who still
go to tentpole movies they're just
different they're just they broken apart
it's over they're trying to put the
genie back in the bottle it's not gonna
happen too late sorry haha
sad sad for Hollywood okay before we go
I've got to talk about Alex Jones again
because why wouldn't I those frogs are
still going gay there's still they
haven't even we need a little conversion
therapy for those frogs maybe now that's
gonna that's what this is really all
about so there is a piece in CNN titled
we need to talk about Alex Jones no you
don't but sure go on they there is some
unbelievable stuff in here the first
writer it's just a series of colonists
giving their opinion of Alex Jones and
you know should people be censored for
having unpopular or wacky points of view
or should we allow free expression the
answer if you're an American is the
latter that is the answer but these
people are clearly anti-american so the
first one raffia Zakaria says quote the
stripping of Infowars through Facebook
Apple and other platforms is an
important step in the recognition of
nativist nationalist and white
supremacist eight speech as a form of
terrorism so first of all I didn't know
that Alex Jones the shortlist vitamin
salesman is a white supremacist I don't
see any evidence of that whatsoever but
they just throw these words around right
I mean you had those those little white
girls the other day shouting through a
bullhorn at Candace Owens a black woman
and saying F white supremacy white white
girls telling a black woman what to do
and yelling at her for not behaving
that's why that's fighting white
supremacy right no of course not that is
white supremacy but here see what they
do they say that speech is a form of
terrorism they use the word hates
the phrase hate speech which doesn't
mean anything there's no meaning to hate
speech their speech there's no legal
hate speech there's no constitutional
provision against hate speech they just
hate speeches for the left speech that
they disagree with but then they're
saying that speech is a form of
terrorism listen to that I mean that is
some wacky stuff if it's terrorism man
they can waterboard you to stop you from
talking right if there is no limit
you are not your speech is no longer
protected by the Geneva Convention you
cannot talk man shut up that's what
she's saying she's saying shut up or
we're gonna waterboard you we're gonna
bring in a Gitmo and torture you that's
what that's what they're saying that
wasn't even the craziest thing
it was pretty wacky Josh McCord her
writing in that same CNN article says
some speech must lose its freedom in our
advanced conception of a nation the idea
that anyone should be able to air any
thought they have just a side note
anyone is not they anyone is he it's a
single it's not a plural word right it's
he and he is the gender-neutral pronoun
I'm sorry this is a minor point on
language not vay there's no singular of
a give me a break did you did this guy
Josh McCord or fail or jot rather John
McWhorter failed the second grade I'm
not good whether they have whether real
insight or not has a gut-level appeal a
hundred years ago and Alex Jones could
only have reached most people via quiet
printed pages written in formal prose
okay so they always do this they always
say we're in the advanced stage now
we're in the advanced stage of the
nation this is not the old stuff that we
did in the old nation that's over forget
the old stuff it's the new stuff now
we're not in an advanced stage we're in
a nation you're not that advanced
definitely John McWhorter is not
advanced he doesn't know how to use
pronouns he's not this is not there's no
but they would say it's so advanced now
all the things that have always been
true throughout human history they're
not true anymore because those guys were
in advance we're advanced they do this
when they want to redistribute wealth
when they want to change the nature of
business when they want to change the
relationship of the state to the
individual they always say so no we're
advanced now forget the old stuff that's
one point the other point where he's
just not quite right is the idea that in
the old days nobody
could communicate with anybody you know
the Protestant revolution began because
of the printing press Martin Luther
wrote a little note and it's spread like
wildfire throughout all of Europe
certainly throughout all of Germany the
lincoln-douglas debates
you know the lincoln-douglas debates
would have crowds 15,000 people at them
that's not just reaching nobody that's
not just a quiet little essay or
something like that William Jennings
Bryan would give you know the populist
Democrat he would give speeches to
15,000 people with with regularity that
you could reach people before I know you
think that everything was invented
yesterday nothing before you ever
existed these things existed there's
nothing new here I've got to say goodbye
we're running a little late today before
I go look that was CNN you know you know
what CNN is CNN is fake news CNN is the
happiest of the bunch but I'm really
pleased that now the star of CNN Jim
Acosta is admitting this here I present
to you for your consideration for Best
Motion Picture best short film of all
time Jim Acosta journalists are the
enemy of the people literally the the
people but I'll say that the press is
the enemy of the people and you know I
don't understand simple sentences so
maybe we should make some bumper
stickers make some buttons you know
maybe we should go out on Pennsylvania
Avenue like these folks who chant CNN's
and fake news maybe we should go out all
all journalists should go out on
Pennsylvania Avenue and shanty NN Senate
the enemy of the people because I'm
tired of this honestly Brooke I'm tired
of this I see NN is not right
Indiana's and it is not fair it is not
just an end is unamerican at the very
least I think we should all be able to
agree on one thing and that is the DNS
the fake news and CNN sucks and CNN's
lost sight of that here at this one
house somebody sent that to me on
Twitter really incredible work I mean
they deserve for best popular movie for
that new Oscar category whoever made
that clip
certainly deserves to win it that's our
show get your mailbag questions in so if
we can answer them tomorrow I will see
you then in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
hair and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018